My name is Adaobi Frank and I'm a
Google Certified Associate Android Developer.
I started mobile development when I left school,
and I was based in Abuja. That was where I was raised,
that was where my parents lived.
My husband knew that I wanted to further my education and my career,
but over the years things had been really hard,
So we haven't had that opportunity.
So the next thing was to do certification courses
to boost my resume, basically
make me more hireable.
I had a job that required me to move to Lagos for six months.
I was like the only female until a team from Andela came to join the project.
I think that was the first time I had even heard of the
scholarship program to get the Google Android Certification.
When I got the email that I had qualified I called
my husband, "Yes! We have the scholarship!"
I was struggling for time.
I was already working a contract job in Lagos.
I would watch these videos on my way to work or on my way back,
so I would with my headphones and with my phone.
All the time.
When I just finished the certification, I actually got a call
for a job offer based in Abuja.
This is something that will make me earn...
More than ten times than the salary that I was earning before.
Ten times, I kid you not.
The interview process was something that would
normally take like weeks,
was like, a couple of days.
'Oh, you are Android Certified? Great. Awesome.'
It was an amazing moment when she got the seal.
And the pay began to pick some bills:
Rent, and go to help us to fix the cars.
She's been amazing. She's been supportive, she's helped me.
So now, I'm like working from my house.
And I can actually call myself a developer.
Not like, 'Oh, in my community I'm awesome.'
In the world. I am OK.
Awesome, we are trying to be awesome, but... OK.